as counselor Deanna Troi on the sci-fi
TV series Star Trek The Next Generation
British American actor Marina Sirtis
played one of the most iconic female
characters in the Star Trek franchise
keep watching to catch up with this
talented actress and find out what she's
up to today to boldly go although next
generation came to a close in 1994 that
wasn't the end of sia toises work with
the federation she reprised her role as
counselor troi in all four
next-generation films alongside much of
the original next-generation cast Troy
also popped up in three episodes of Star
Trek Voyager from 1999 to 2000 and also
in the 2005 series finale of Star Trek
Enterprise marking her last appearance
as Deanna Troi though with the planned
return of Captain jean-luc Picard in a
new Star Trek series on the horizon can
she be too far behind
[Music]
Godwin's after the next generation see
itís began voice acting joining the cast
of the Disney animated series gargoyles
from 1994 to 1996 theatres voiced Damona
a villain with a thirst for vengeance
against the humans that slaughtered her
clan while many fans who approached
citta sick conventions of fanciful work
in both Star Trek and gargoyles
she says that quite a few preferred
Damona over the more passive deanna
theaters wasn't the only next-generation
actor that ended up on GOG woods
Jonathan Frakes appeared as David
sanitized Michael Dorn played cold stone
and brent Spiner voiced Park that wasn't
the end daughter she provided the voice
of antagonist queen bee and several
other characters in the Cartoon Network
animated series Young Justice and a dog
warrior on Adventure Time among other
shows in video games the Stars have
paired you with a goddess I like the way
you talk but you are crazy
notably she displayed matriarch benezia
in 2007 s Mass Effect and most recently
Elena
dragon OVA in 2014's ex-con to war of
the chosen back to sci-fi after taking
some time away from traditional sci-fi
with roles in mystery themed productions
like gadget man and Diagnosis Murder
satis returned to science fiction in
1999 with role in the Showtime series
the Outer Limits in the Grell Shear
displays live Cola whose family finds
themselves in a moral quandary when
their alien slave demonstrates an
unexpected loyalty to them forcing her
and her husband to rethink their bigoted
worldview in 2000 Shearer dismayed an
appearance in another popular science
fiction franchise which guest-starred as
Russian scientist dr. Svetlana Markov in
the Stargate sg-1 episode Watergate in
the episode Markov struggles with a
broken Stargate body controlling aliens
and a mysteriously murdered crew of
course it's nothing that Deanna Troi
hasn't seen before
hey she followed this up with a couple
of guest spots in the British Hospital
drama casualty and it's spin-off series
Holby City but that wasn't all
she also picked up brief roles in a
variety of American TV shows but before
long it was back to sci-fi again
annihilation earth and Beyond in 2009
cirrus landed a starring role in the
sci-fi movie annihilation earth as
Paxton the leader of the secretive UN
energy project called Eve whose
decisions will determine the fate of
mankind again not too far from Troy's
deep space adventures
in 2015 she appeared in the
investigative thriller a dark reflection
a British indie film directed and
produced by former British Airways pilot
Tristan Lorraine in order to expose an
alleged cover-up involving toxic cabin
air in commercial jets NCIS from 2013 to
2016 ciertas played a recurring role on
the police procedural drama NCIS as
Mossad director only elbows elbows takes
over the position as Israel's top spy in
the show's tenth season and subsequently
appears in episodes during season 11 and
the season 13 finale
according to cirrus she didn't have to
read for the role and was thrilled to
have been offered the pod Sirius told
The AV Club I love to play strong women
I love it because that's who I am and
she can kick anyone's ass new life and
new civilizations Sirius is showing no
signs of slowing down
notwithstanding her time-traveling
adventures in sharknado 6 the last
sharknado or appearing in little dead
rotting hood she signed on for a second
season episode of the Orville Seth
MacFarlane sci-fi comedy on Fox not
coincidentally her episode will also be
directed by fellow next-gen alum and
former on-screen boyfriend Jonathan
Frakes more than any other next gen star
Sirius seems willing to put on a
Starfleet uniform again and again almost
assuring fans that we'll be seeing her
again as Deanna Troi in CBS's upcoming
series based on fan favorite Captain
jean-luc Picard Megaton
sir
do it